Determina la altura de un cilindro de volumen 16 pi por "n" a la quinta y base cuyo radio es 2n.
¿Ok? Déjame dibujar por aquí un cilindro para acordarnos de cómo se calcula su volumen,
esto de aquí es la tapa del cilindro.
Es un círculo, aquí tenemos los lados, los lados del cilindro
y finalmente voy a dibujar aquí un cachito de la base,
es nada más la parte que se ve,
bueno es más deja de dibujar aquí con línea punteada la parte de atrás,
indicando que si el cilindro fuera transparente entonces también se vería eso.
Bueno pensemos que este cilindro tiene altura "h",
la altura de este cilindro es "h",
lo voy a marcar así, esto de aquí es "h" y pensemos que el área de la base del cilindro, es "a" ¿Va?
Entonces el área de la base es "a".
Si conocemos la altura y el área de la base de un cilindro, podemos determinar su volumen,
multiplicando esas dos cantidades,
multiplicando la altura, la altura con el área de la base.
Sin embargo lo que a nosotros nos piden es determinar "h", la altura, esto es lo que nos están preguntando.
Vamos a ver qué información nos dan.
A ver, pues nos dicen que el volumen, el volumen es de 16pi,
es no es el color de volumen, 16pi "n" a la quinta entonces, estoy de acá es 16
16pi y "n" a la quinta ,
y además nos dicen que la base,
la base tiene radio 2n.
La base es un círculo ¿Verdad?
Bueno la base y la tapa son iguales, son círculos y tienen radio 2n pero, aquí tenemos el área de la base.
Afortunadamente conocemos el área de un círculo a partir de su radio
es de las primeras cosas que aprendimos
en geometría y tenemos que esa área es igual a pi,
pi por radio al cuadrado entonces, vamos a determinar el área de la base ¿Va? Entonces tenemos
que poner aquí pi, y sabemos que el radio es 2 n entonces, teníamos que poner en vez de "r", 2 n
2n al cuadrado vamos a ver cuánto nos queda, nos quedaría que el área es igual a pi
a ver aquí tenemos que elevar 2 al cuadrado
2 al cuadrado que es 4 y multiplicar por "n" al cuadrado, por
"n" al cuadrado, déjame reacomodarlo para que se vea un poco más bonito, lo voy a poner como 4pi
"n" cuadrada muy bien. Entonces esto de aquí es el área de la base ahora sí podemos encontrar "h".
Entonces déjame escribir la igualdad que tenemos hasta ahorita, tenemos que el volumen que es 16pi
por "n" a la quinta es igual a "h" lo que queremos determinar
multiplicado por el área que ya determinamos, multiplicado por 4
4pi "n" al cuadrado
entonces es un muy buen primer paso para despejar "h".
¡Bueno! Creo que el único paso para despejar "h" que tenemos que hacer,
es dividir entre 4pi "n" cuadrado
ambos lados de esta igualdad. Déjame hacer esto, voy a dibujar aquí entre 4pi "n" cuadrada
4pi "n" cuadrada, de este lado también voy a dibujar entre 4pi
"n" cuadrada y vamos a simplificar a ver que nos queda
del lado derecho, se cancelan estos dos términos justo ese fue el chiste de
dividir entre 4pi "n" cuadrada ¿Verdad?
Entonces del lado derecho simplemente nos queda "h"
"h" y nos queda que "h" es igual a,
y vamos a ver si podemos simplificar lo de la izquierda, si podemos simplificarlo
bastantito ¿Verdad? A ver mira este pi se cancela con éste pi,
pi entre pi es igual a 1 entonces, no nos importa, este 16 entre
4, 16 entre 4 es 4, lo voy a cancelar así, le voy a poner queda 4 entonces es
4 por
y vamos con las "n",  aquí tenemos "n" a la quinta, aquí tenemos "n" al cuadrado, podemos utilizar
leyes de los exponentes ¿Verdad? Si aquí abajo tenemos un exponente,
podemos restárselo al exponente de arriba
entonces nos quedaría "n" a las 5 -2, 5-2 es 3 entonces, sería 4 por "n" por "n"
cúbica muy bien entonces,
determinamos que la altura de nuestro cilindro
es igual a 4n cúbica.